you're going to find a landlord and
force them to be poor
and then when they become poor then go
and find another rich person and steal
off them to give to that landlord and
then they become poor and just make
everybody poor
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
i want to talk about what's happening
right now within property and the
government
there was a big announcement yesterday
which to be honest
i'm not really that happy about and
neither should you be as a property
investor or as a landlord or someone
that wants to get into property
and i'm going to give you the facts
about what's happened
i'm going to inform you and then i'm
going to talk about what we need to do
as landlords to stand against this
because
i'm getting very very frustrated with
the government actually right now
who are supposed to be supporting
businesses who are supposed to be
wanting to see the economy get picked
back
up so this video is very likely going to
get seen
by the government it will be probably
seen by people in high
places and you know believe it or not
you can petition and you can
protest but actually it's videos like
this and it's people like me speaking up
and saying hello
this is what's happening and this is how
i feel about it as a property investor
in the landlord
and actually i train tens of thousands
of property investors and landlords and
this is how we feel
collectively about it so if you're
watching this video please do
listen be informed you need to know
what's going on and also
if you agree with me please comment
below
and let me know why and let me know your
thoughts now that's not for me
that's not for me just to be able to go
oh look lots of people agree with me
isn't it great
that's because the more people that
comment on this video and say
i agree this is outrageous this needs to
stop
boris hello do something the more people
stand up and speak up on this video
i mean it means that when people see it
they'll see the comments and they'll
think oh maybe there's actually a lot of
people said this is
in its own way this is a protest this is
a protest so please
comment below if you agree with me but
first let me tell you what's happened
so yesterday they announced that they
were gonna
ban tenant evictions for another
four weeks now just to put this into
perspective
for all throughout this whole pandemic
lockdown situation
we have not been able to evict tenants
so if a tenant is not paying their rent
you can't evict them which to be honest
i kind of understood for a little while
at first i thought fair enough
everyone was really shook up they didn't
know what was happening but but now
this is getting beyond a little bit of a
joke because
landlords just because you own
properties or own a property
it doesn't mean that you're rich it
doesn't mean that you're able to just
accept not receiving rent now some
landlords might be rich
but if they're not receiving rent then
they'll very quickly be poor
and the houses are going to go
repossessed and then suddenly
no tenants are going to have anywhere to
live so just saying you cannot ban a
tenant so you cannot evict a tenant
i just don't think he's good enough now
listen maybe
you might want to say under certain
circumstances and you want
stricter the eviction rules i understand
that
but government that is not what you have
done what you've done is you've banned
evictions all together so if you if i've
got a tenant living in the house
they could be a a a young bachelor
renting a 10 000 pound per month mansion
throwing parties deliberately not paying
rent because they know that they can't
be evicted
and guess what as a landlord there's
nothing
you can do now listen if you're a tenant
watching this please don't think that
you can get away with that because you
can't
because eventually it will catch up with
you and when this little
holiday period of paying rent is over
you'll be evicted and you'll be dealt
with
also if any of my tenants are watching
this and i know some of my tenants do
watch my videos
i just want to say pretty much every
single one of my tenants
is paying their rent right now in full
and there's a couple of people whereby
they've had
very extreme circumstances where we've
reduced their rent and
i am working with them but i don't think
and thank you by the way um my tenants
for being for being a good
human being and i believe in just being
a good human being
and why don't you government rather than
forcing landlords
to not not be able to get rent why don't
you just
rely on a little bit of goodwill because
every
situation is different some landlords
are on the bread line
if you've got 10 houses and each house
is making you a hundred pound a month
that's a thousand pound a month that's
your salary you have so many attendants
not paying their rent
you've still got to pay the mortgage and
and mortgage holiday by the way is not
is is not really a thing
because you got you have a mortgage
holiday you're still gonna have to pay
that
back at some point and what's happening
the government are giving out bounce
back loans and stuff trying to make
these amateur landlords um reliant and
dependent on the government because as
soon as you're dependent on the
government the government have complete
control
and i am so anti what is happening right
now
i mean how about just looking at the
situation what about if
if the tenant isn't affected by the
virus at all
they're just using it as an excuse now i
get it sometimes it's a genuine reason
but
i think we need to look at things on a
case by case that's my opinion
let me know your thoughts comment below
i need to know your thoughts as i say
people are going to be watching this
video
they're going to be looking at the gist
of the comments so please do comment
this is our petition right now
shelter jumping on the bandwagon who
said they helped the homeless
shelter come on get real i've been on
the receiving end of shelter that help
the homeless
and actually what shelter often do is
they just help tenants
legally not pay rent that's not helping
the homeless
i think it's immoral i think it's
unethical so honestly
listen if you're all pro tenants having
free rent right now
then how about people having free food
right now
how about we just go to sainsbury's and
we just take food and we just go to
waitrose and we just take whatever
regardless of how expensive it is
what about we just don't why don't we
just go and get mobile phones we just
take them from
from car phone warehouse and we just
start getting free stuff of course
what would happen is that would cause
absolute habit
mayhem and it would ruin the economy so
why
pick on landlords and say oh well
they're rich and
they they can just let tenants pay rent
free no
it needs to stop also another
annoying piece of news is that now when
you're evict attendant you have to give
six months notice and this is after the
eviction ban has finished
up until at least march the 31st of 2021
and this is something that i don't like
it's all this at least this date and
then we're going to just extend it again
extend it again i really feel we just
need to know where we stand what is
happening what is going on
another reason this is so annoying right
now is because
rents are really going up certainly in
the areas that i'm buying properties
and there's a massive lineup for people
wanting properties
but instead the properties are just
taken up by people just who don't want
to pay rent
come on it's not fair so what do i think
should happen what do i think is fair
i think firstly it would be fair to look
at things on a case by case but i think
also it would be fair to say
at the end of this four weeks how about
we just say right
we'll extend it for four weeks but then
that's it we don't want
another extension of the eviction ban
and then you're saying
march the 31st until at least that day
you're gonna have to give six months
later want to just say
actually you know what march 31st then
we're good again
stop messing us around stop messing
around and playing games this
is serious because there's a lot of
landlords that are on the bread line and
then what's gonna happen when the
landlords start moving they're
losing their houses losing their money
are you gonna then
pay their rent government are you gonna
then start helping them out and
rock what you do you're gonna you're
gonna find a landlord and force them to
be poor
and then when they become poor they're
gonna find another rich person and steal
off them to give to that landlord and
then they become poor and just make
everybody poor
i just think that's a messed up warped
system
i actually think the opposite should be
happening we should be creating
opportunities
to help the poor become wealthy not by
not by taking
off of the rich it's really got to stop
again please
comment as part of your petition if you
agree with me and if you think
really things need to change and they
need to change now now i'm an optimist i
always like to draw positives
out of a negative situation so i guess
the positives are for one it's good
because this is gonna
put off a lot of landlords and investors
which means that there'll be
more deals for the serious people and
for the people that are going to be
creative there's always creative ways to
get around this
i mean for a start one of the things
that i'm doing and one of the things
that i teach actively to most of my
students
is serviced accommodation where you get
a lot more rent but also
none of these nonsense rules apply when
you're renting out a property
as serviced accommodation short stay
less higher rent
this doesn't apply so listen if you're
buying a property right now and you're
worried about putting
a tenant in in case they don't pay you
the rent and you can't get them out
maybe consider using service
accommodation if you can't and if you've
got current problems or you've got
tenants and it's difficult
what i would say is a little piece of
advice from experience is pick up the
phone and
speak to your tenants relationship is
key
most people are good people i say
there's only uh there's only five bad
tenants in the world they just move
around from house to house a lot
when you when you get i don't i don't
want to create an us versus them
you know a landlord versus tenant
because i love my tenants
and they're my customers and they pay me
and that's what enables me to have the
lifestyle that i have so i really want
to create this us versus them thing
it's not landlord versus tenant at all
it's
the people versus this terrible messed
up system that needs to change so do
something
needs to change this is my voice this is
my petition
this is my protest please comment below
they will watch this
i know because sometimes the bigger
corporations get my videos taken down
sometimes which means that at least they
watch it so comment
and uh let's see some change